[Music]
welcome Tara she's here she's based at
George Washington University you'll hear
a little bit more about the wave lab
that she runs there and her subject
tonight is obviously something bringing
together the latest technology and and
something we're aware of right now but
as as she's going to say it's
surveillances is not actually a new
topic and we're excited to fir to give
us a long view on what it has meant and
what it will mean going forward please a
big round of applause for Tara Behrens
[Applause]
hi everyone well thank you for that
introduction and thank you to the long
now foundation for inviting me to be
here with you tonight I'm really excited
to talk to you about surveillance I know
this is a topic of the moment I am
scared about surveillance I'm sure all
of you are but this is not a talk about
being afraid it's a talk about how
organizations use surveillance and how
that might affect individual behavior
both for bad and possibly for good so
before I get into the research I want to
talk to you about today let me just say
a few words about Who I am and what my
perspective is so I'm a psychologist
psychology is the study of behavior
individual behavior more specifically
I'm an organizational psychologist which
is the study of people in organizations
and we have two goals the first goal is
to maximize the well-being of individual
human beings and organizations I think
that's a lofty goal the second goal is
to maximize the productivity of the
organization as a whole and we can think
about organizations as including
institutions like government agency is
an educational institutions and
nonprofits so these are all the kinds of
organizations that someone like me might
work with and we tend to follow this
model of the sign
practitioner model meeting our science
is informed by what's actually happening
in real organizations and when we work
with organizations we use scientific
best practice to inform how they should
operate I think the best way to
understand the scientists practitioner
model also sets up when I want to talk
to you about today which is surveillance
so this is a question that
organizational psychologists have been
thinking about for at least 100 years
the most famous example has come to be
called the Hawthorne studies okay so the
Hawthorne electric plant in Chicago was
struggling with productivity they said
why are workers not being productive and
so they called in a few management
professors to come figure out what was
going on and the management professors
took a look around and they said well
it's really dim in here
let's try raising the lighting so they
raised the lighting and productivity
went up it was amazing they were so
proud of themselves for figuring it out
but they said we should be good
scientists let's try a few more things
so let's raise the lighting again raise
the lighting again productivity went up
again they said all right we figured it
out but let's just be sure well lower
the lighting and see what happened so
they lower the lighting productivity
went up again okay so it's not about the
lighting this is what they could
conclude right instead they realized
being good scientists that perhaps the
workers in this organization were not
passive objects being observed but
perhaps they were aware that they were
being observed in changing their
behavior accordingly right and so
whatever the explanation may be they
were trying to help the experiment be
successful maybe they were kind of happy
that someone in some fancy Harvard
Business School person was there
observing them maybe they were just on
their best behavior because somebody is
watching but regardless we can conclude
that people change their behavior when
they're being watched this should be a
surprise to nobody
and of course people act differently
when they're being watched this is the
first time that we observe this in this
sort of context but of course this
question is much older than 100 years
old all right we can go back and think
about how philosophers have been
exploring this question we can go back
as far as Plato in Plato's Republic
there is a story about a person named
guy geez
I'm guide Jesus a fellow who somehow
obtained a ring that made him invisible
is amazing so he can do whatever he
wants and what did he do well he killed
the king all right married the Queen
used this this power to behave quite
evil Eve or a morally at least and the
reason this is in the Republic is it's a
debate about what happens when people
are not held accountable for their
behavior when they can do whatever they
want the argument here is that maybe we
all act like evil animals when no one's
watching us I don't agree with that
argument of course but this is the kind
of question that is being posed are we
really moral or does somebody need to
watch us to make us be moral okay
this line of inquiry continued in the in
the 1800s Jeremy Bentham and this is the
panopticon here some of you are probably
familiar with the idea of the panoptic
on the idea is a hypothetical prison
where you can't tell if the guard is
watching you or not so you always have
to be on your best behavior just in case
the guard is watching you are used to it
you don't even need real surveillance
you just need the possibility of
surveillance and you will then behave
properly okay um
common to both of these arguments is the
idea that the point of surveillance is
to make people behave okay but that's
not the only way to think about
surveillance um around 1900 a
psychologist named Triplett observed
cyclists and he noticed that when the
cyclists were practicing for a race they
turned in faster times when they were
racing with their buddies and slower
times when they were racing with they're
by themselves you've probably
experienced something like this yourself
yes I see a lot of nodding it's
something about having other people
around you improves your performance and
triplet called this idea of social
facilitation but he didn't really know
why it worked or what was going on he
just knew that people's performance was
better when they were surrounded by
their friends and so for the next 50
years psychologists tried to figure out
what was going on here and they ran all
sorts of different experiments to try to
replicate this effect of social
facilitation and sometimes performance
went up when other people were around
sometimes it went down sometimes nothing
happened and it was very confusing okay
around the 60s a psychologist a social
psychologist named Bob Zion showed up
and give some real clarity to this up to
this phenomenon so Bob Zions proposed
what he called Drive theory which is
that the effects of having people around
you're watching you depend on what
you're doing what task you're doing okay
you're doing a simple task like six
minus one who knows the answer to that
one okay yes it's easy having other
people around makes it even easier okay
but when you're doing a complex task
like this one who knows this one nobody
huh
then the the effect of having people
around you is negative so we can say
that the social the people observing you
enhance whatever your dominant response
is if your dominant response is success
you get more successful if it's failure
then you get more terrible if any of you
are athletes or you know if you shoot
pool in a bar you know that if you're
good at something having people around
you makes you even better it kind of
gives you that stimulation but if you're
bad at it then the people around you
make it even harder to focus because
it's a source of distraction okay so
this is what we know generally speaking
about social facilitation currently but
I'm interested in electronic
surveillance right what's different when
the thing watching you is not your buddy
but a computer or device of some sort so
electronic surveillance is different for
a lot of reasons four of them are up
here one is that it's focused just on
you
okay the crowd can be looking at all
sorts of things not necessarily focusing
on the person but electronic
surveillance tend to focus only on the
individual performing it's invisible you
have to wonder and so here is that
panopticon effect again you don't know
if you're being watched or not this is a
problem it's permanent
meaning if your boss is watching you at
work they're not documenting everything
they observe and filing it away but
electronic surveillance does create a
permanent record and so it's potentially
more threatening to you and then finally
it's continuous electronic surveillance
doesn't take a bathroom break alright so
for all of these reasons
it's possible that electronic
surveillance behaves differently than
individual human being surveillance okay
the other difference that's really
important when it comes to electronic
surveillance it's not how you're being
watched but what is being watched
it's not just your body but perhaps your
thoughts all right your email contains
your your intimate thoughts what you say
and how you say it it gets more into the
psychological and less into the physical
a good example of this is something
called a sociometric badge it's
something that was originally developed
in the MIT Media Lab and there's now
been spun off into a profit-making
enterprise this is a device you wear
around your neck and it tracks what you
say and how you say it what's the
emotional tone of what you're saying and
so it's it's potentially very useful as
a feedback tool the real power though is
that everyone on your team wears it too
and so now I can track who you talk to
who you interrupt right who's talking
the most there's always one team with a
chatterbox right who's the chatterbox
and I can really get rich information
about what the social dynamics are in a
team the danger though is taking this
descriptive information and making it
prescriptive all right imagine that I
learned something about my team and I'd
say this is amazing
Janet always speaks first that's the
magic formula
let's make Janet speak first at every
meeting and for every team of course
that's faulty logic all right but this
is the kind of logic that surveillance
tends to encourage so my point with all
of this is that electronic surveillance
is a very important cue about what's
important and it drives people's
behavior and changes it accordingly this
could be good or it could be bad
depending on what we're surveilling
those of you that are economists or have
a background in economics might have
heard of good hearts law yes this is the
same principle that when you measure
something and try to use it as a target
it's no longer a good measure and I'll
give you an example of this that might
resonate with you who has a Fitbit
anyone have a Fitbit or something
similar or conser steps okay the idea is
that we know from research that people
who take more
jobs are healthier right this is this is
true so let's make everyone take more
steps and then they'll be healthier
right
no because who's ever been tempted to
put your Fitbit on your dog to write
increase your steps or to eat a
cheeseburger because you met your steps
for that day right so it's great at
focusing your attention on just that one
thing but you lose the whole picture all
right that's the effect of counting
something narrow the attention on just
that thing right that's the real problem
um I'm going to say the same thing I
just said but say it in terms of say it
in terms of psychology and goal-setting
okay so let's assume this is you I'm not
saying this is you but just pretend it's
you for a moment and let's say you've
got a goal to become healthier alright
so you're gonna take up cycling so
motivation is the force that drives your
effort and your persistence towards that
idea of becoming healthier and the goal
is that desired feature state whatever
it is it could be win a race it could be
be healthier it could be look good in my
cycling outfit right um these goals are
not necessarily on sync with each other
and the goal that you choose is really
important okay um since the 90s we've
been talking about which this is my joke
by the way but it is not since the
nineties we've been talking about
potentially negative consequences of
over enthusiastic goal-setting so max
peas were mine deserves credit for this
joke goals gone wild but the ideas that
goals are so effective that they make
you do all kinds of unethical and crazy
things in the service of meeting that
goal I'm a good example from the 70s is
the Ford Pinto right Ford said make me a
car that costs under $2,000 and weighs
under 2,000 pounds and the Ford said you
got it but they forgot to say don't make
it blow up right
[Laughter]
same thing in 2015 right Volkswagen had
some very clear goals about emission
standards and they figured out the best
way was to just buy about it Pisa
goals are greater to chiefing now very
specific behavior that you set but at
the cost of long-term thinking at the
cost of ethical thinking at the cost of
considering people who are not you
alright so this is the downsides of
goal-setting and again electronic
surveillance is a very effective
goal-setting mechanism right whatever
you're measuring becomes the goal to get
even more precise for you and this is a
lot of jargon so bear with me we can
think about the kinds of goals that
somebody might set and categorize them
according to a 2x2 matrix first we can
think about goals as either being
positive or negative approach goals
positive goals mean get something good
right win a prize learn a skill do
something amazing
avoid goals mean avoid something bad
alright like run away from a bear would
be avoid goal or not look foolish in
front of the cute guy or girl in your
study hall all right avoiding bad things
is a totally legitimate kind of goal we
can also organize them according to
whether they are learning focused or
performing focused another way of saying
that is are you trying to really get
better or are you trying to seem better
you're trying to impress people or are
you trying to really develop something
in yourself okay
unfortunately surveillance tends to
encourage performance goals which are
useful in some contexts but really
problematic in other contexts this
matters to me for a lot of reasons one
of the reasons it matters though and
sorry for the gruesome image here is
that in the context of organizations
people need to learn these skills all
the time all right they need to be okay
with not being amazing the first time
they try something if you're a medical
resident learning to perform knee
surgery you can't be worried about how
many seconds it takes you to perform the
surgery the first time you can't be
worried about whether you're out
performing
your buddy you have to really focus on
mastering that skill at first and the
problem with surveillance is that it
makes that goal less likely to happen
has anyone ever heard of the term
personalized learning or adaptive
learning or any of these ideas all of
these educational innovations are based
on the premise that we collect a lot of
data about people and then use it to
give them feedback right to help them
improve their performance but the data
collection itself makes it less likely
that the educational innovation will be
successful because you're focusing the
attention on the thing being measured
and then driving the behavior away from
what you want okay so overall I would
say that listen surveillance is a form
of goal-setting for people it says pay
attention to this information it's
really important because I'm counting it
so you know it's really important that
can be good or it can be bad depending
on what you're counting however and this
is a huge however in fact I'm going to
spend the next 20 minutes with this
however not all people are equal and not
all surveillance is equal so I want to
present two studies to you one targhee
the first point when to argue the second
point about how different people might
react to surveillance and how
surveillance itself can be framed in
such a way as to be more or less
problematic all right so I'm going to
start with the first one not all people
are equal I'm gonna ask you a question
so imagine that you're in your workplace
and there has been a rash of thefts
someone's stealing something you can
invent the thing it's okay and the
management says we're gonna install
surveillance cameras to use some fake
facial recognition and see you know
who's the thief is and we'll keep that
information on record and we might pull
it up in a couple years to do something
with it or not I don't know we'll see
would you be okay with that so your
answers can be yes/no whereas appends
who thinks yes this is acceptable
who thinks no it is completely
unacceptable who thinks it depends on
something okay interesting
so the Pew Center for Internet and
Society conducted this exact survey and
their responses were a little bit
different but the point stands which is
that your answer to this question varies
not everyone feels the same way about
whether this is acceptable in an
interview study that I conducted I found
the same thing so I want to show you a
few quotes I asked people how they felt
about the surveillance that existed in
their organizations so this quote is
from somebody who is not monitored at
all in their organization and you can
see that they said it upsets me that no
one monitors anything it says they don't
care it's really frustrating I think
productivity would go way up if somebody
monitored something all right like I'm
just making up reports just in the blind
attempt that someone will pay attention
to me okay so that's one response the
second response is yeah it's cool that
no one monitors me because I I think my
boss understands the digital age
understands that it's unreasonable to
track those internet usage so this is a
reasonable behavior so two people both
not monitored very different reactions
now this person is monitored they said
you know what it drives me crazy I can't
stand the fact that there might be
nothing to do at work there's no
customers but some security guys
somewhere is watching me alright that
makes me insane I would feel that way to
contrast that with this person who says
you know what I've seen surveillance use
effectively to resolve issues I think
it's great we should surveil more so
this tells me people feel differently
about this issue okay so the question is
why do they feel differently about this
issue what can we learn about people
that might suggest why they react to
surveillance in a particular way and the
way that we come out this question might
depend on your perspective so if you're
an economist I love economists I don't
know why I pick on them so much if
you're an economist you might take a
kind of privacy calculus perspective you
might say that people are okay giving up
some information about themselves as
long as they get something in return all
right so we saw that person you said
I've seen it used to resolve issues so
I'm fine with it
I can I can be okay with this practice
you might take a different perspective
though you might take a perspective of
values and even saying the word
authoritarian makes me feel slightly bad
these days but if you're an
authoritarian you tend to support
surveillance right for the same reason
that the Philosopher's were talking
about to enforce good behavior you might
feel like people need to be surveilled
or they'll act out if you're a
collectivist collectivists tend to
values of welfare of the group over
their own individual welfare they tend
to think about their identity as part of
a group identity which means their own
individual information is actually not
so precious that they need to protect it
and so collectivist might actually care
less about individual privacy as long as
it supports the group okay um I'm those
are great I'm actually interested in
personality as a predictor so I want to
present to you some research that I did
about how people's personality is might
drive how they react to surveillance
okay just as a refresher in case you're
not a personality psychologist just in
case the the dominant model of
personality research is the Big Five
model also called the ocean model and we
can think about these five variables you
can be high or low on either of them you
don't have to pick a variable right
being open doesn't mean you're not an
extrovert and just quickly
open-mindedness tends to refer to how
receptive you are to new ideas so people
who are high in openness they like to go
to art museums they like to think they
tend to vote for liberal political
candidates this is open-mindedness and
conscientiousness has to do with rules
and orderliness
so if your closet looks like this you're
probably conscientious if you're very
punctual if you if you care a lot about
order you're conscientious extraversion
has to do with liking to be around other
people liking to be social so if you
like to go to parties if you find that
your best ideas come from talking to
other people that's extraversion
agreeableness is kindness and compassion
so it's different than being around
other people you can be a jerk and
to be around other people to yell at
them all the time right but
agreeableness is more about actually
caring about them and the neuroticism
has to do with the tendency to
experience negative emotions so if you
experience stress very easily if things
bother you very easily
that's neurotic it's not a judgement
statement it's actually all of these yes
all of these can be bad in either
extreme and so you shouldn't feel any
you shouldn't feel any stress if you're
neurotic is what I'm telling you okay
all right um so this is the Big Five
model of personality in addition to this
Big Five model there's another variable
that's important to understand just
called impression management everybody
engages in impression management
sometimes if you're on a job interview
if you're on a date the impression
management means attempting to put
forward a good impression to make
someone else like you so we all do it
sometimes people vary however in how
much they do it
so some people always are concerned
about putting forward a good face and
impressing others and doing what
everyone else is doing so if you have a
habit of kind of reading the room before
you act right that's impression
management other people really don't
care they do what they want right and
they figure so what if people don't like
me so then you be low and impression
management okay so this is not a sixth
personality variable but rather it tells
us how likely it is that you display
your real personality depending on this
situation all right if your hind
impression management you might be like
late I can withhold that okay all right
so to understand how this personality
patterns might affect surveillance
perceptions I use data from the my
personality org project the my
personality project is a Facebook app
that was active from 2009 to 2012 some
of you might have downloaded it six
million people did and if you downloaded
this app it asks you a series of
questions the first thing it did is say
take a personality test and we'll give
you your feedback and it will be
wonderful and you'll know what your
personality is the second thing it's at
is by the way
we see your Facebook profile just to
give you more information about your
personality so this is the first kind of
privacy variable that I was able to
obtain did you agree to share your
profile with some stranger on the
Internet just because they asked and
then the third step is that the app
captured any profile photos that you
made available publicly okay so you know
it's a different it was a different time
2009 and so it that question made more
sense before but the idea is any put any
photos that you set to public the app
would just collect okay so this is
another measure of how much you care
about privacy all right
so let me show you what this with this
data yielded the first thing is shocking
to me actually which is that most people
said sure you can see my facebook
profile in in 2009 almost 70% of people
said yes in 2010 about 50% of people
said yes so I the rest of the analyses
here then focus on 2010 when about half
of people said yes half people said no
it was about a million people I'm in
this dataset alright so before I get to
personality the first thing I looked at
perhaps the most obvious thing was
whether there were gender and age
effects in whether people shared their
data and this is a surprise to me but
there was not any major age effect so
you can see that 18 to 24 year olds were
the most likely to share but they were
followed by a 35 to 44 year olds so for
the most part people are equally willing
to share their information depending on
their age and as far as gender there's a
small but consistent effect of gender
and that men are slightly more likely to
share than women but this is not a
dramatic effect we're talking less than
five percentage points so without
further adue personality so I wanted to
look at again whether personality
variable is predicted whether people
would share their data with a random
stranger on the Internet
and the data is pretty interesting here
so the first thing we observe here is
that conscientious people care more
about their privacy which makes sense
they care about rules they're cautious
we shouldn't straight share with
strangers and open-minded people care
less about privacy they're open right
they like to share things so so far
pretty logical it's also noteworthy that
impression managers again those are
people who are trying to impress you
cared the least about privacy right so
they're sharing the most with you and
I'll come back to why I think that's
really important in a moment but this is
just one variable I also looked at
whether their photo was public remember
and when he looks at that the pattern
was totally different so open-minded
people now care more about privacy
conscientious people care less about
privacy and now agreeableness and
extraversion show up for the party too
and so depending on the kind of privacy
behavior were interested in the
predictors are different that's
important all privacy is not the same
right people make this decision on a
case-by-case basis depending on what's
being asked of them and there's
something different about giving your
profile to a person who asked for it
versus putting a photo out there into
the world for anyone to see alright the
predictors of those two behaviors are
totally different this is not surprising
so I wanted to keep looking at this this
at this idea of this pattern the next
way I looked at this data was by
grouping people into theoretically
meaningful categories based on their
whole personality profile at once so the
first category conspiracy theorists
conspiracy theorists are defined by
being very high in openness meaning
they're willing to entertain new ideas
even if they're perhaps a little on the
conspiracy side and they tend to be
highly neuroticism meaning they get
stressed out and nervous easily so if
you get stressed out and nervous easily
and you're very very open-minded that
happens to be the kind of person that
believes in conspiracies doesn't mean
that any individual person is a
conspiracy theorist but this is this is
the pattern the second pattern is
impression managers and I I categorize
this a little bit differently here here
impression managers or people who told
me that they have every positive trait
and no negative traits right so
you said I'm just an amazing wonderful
person in every way you're a liar and
you're an oppression manager okay so so
that those are the two categories that I
was really most interested in I thought
you know I thought that conspiracy
theorists would be more concerned about
privacy and impression managers would be
less concerned about privacy and then
the third category is everyone else I
don't care about them so so it turns out
that I was partially right if I looked
at how many profile images people made
available there was no difference in
people's personalities but if I look
more closely at the photos and check to
see if there was a face in them like are
you actually showing your face or is it
just a cartoon cat all right well the
impression managers are more likely to
show their face and the conspiracy
theorists are less likely to show their
face okay so pretty consistent with what
we would expect okay so as far as
answering this question just personality
protect sharing or does it predict
attitudes about privacy
um the I think the biggest take-home is
that impression management absolutely
does predict sharing and there are a few
different contrasting explanations for
why that might be the first one is that
I've scrubbed my profile so carefully
because I'm trying to impress everyone
that sharing doesn't matter
there's nothing terrible in there all
right so who cares let everyone see it
the other explanation is that someone
has asked something of me and I want
them to like me so I give them my data
right a third explanation and this is I
confess too wildly speculating at this
point a third explanation is that when
I'm the hind impression management Who I
am changes based on the situation all
right so sharing it doesn't really
matter like I don't feel very closely
connected to that thing that I'm sharing
and so it has less value for me this is
almost an economic argument again that
my personal information has less value
so I'm willing to give it to someone who
asks and I can't tell you based on this
data which of those explanations is the
most true or if any of them are true
well this is what I suspect okay now I
want to go back remember I started off
by saying that not all people are equal
and not all surveillance is equal so now
I want to return to that second point
not all surveillance is equal and I want
to show you
for a mental study I conducted to
explore how characteristics of the
surveillance itself might affect how it
seemed how it affects people's behavior
and specifically I looked at how the
surveillance is framed and communicated
to people okay now if we think that our
personalized learning and adaptive
learning kinds of examples those also
use surveillance right we can frame
surveillance as we're watching you to
check up on you because we think you're
terrible and needs to be babysat or we
can frame it as we're collecting
personalized information to give you a
better experience of some sort all right
those have very different feelings one
is Big Brother and one is Microsoft
Clippy here to help you right so one is
threatening one is not threatening even
though the behavior is the same and the
surveillance is the same so I explored
these two frames in the context of
people learning how to use advanced
Microsoft Excel functions B lookup pivot
tables things like this so we asked them
to come in to an experiment learn how to
use pivot tables which who doesn't love
a good pivot table and and then we told
them we're monitoring you and we give
them one of these two frames either to
make sure you do everything you're
supposed to do or because we're trying
to give you a better experience and so
we showed them this fake report that
showed all the things that would be
collected about them you know the
details of this are not important and
then we asked them to engage in a video
test it had clearly in red letters that
were monitoring you to remind people and
then at the end of each module they
completed a little test like what symbol
do you use to refer to a different
worksheet so it's a little declarative
knowledge test and then it's it's small
to see but what you can see is that it
says you spent 75 seconds on this video
you should have spent 180 seconds so go
back watch that video again okay and
this is one of the behaviors that we
were interested in do people go back and
watch the video again I'm and then at
the very end of the training they did a
skills test so we gave them a worksheet
and said use some pivot tables on this
worksheet to solve some problems all
right so we have some different learning
outcomes
based on again that declarative nod test
the behavior and the final skills test
and we had three conditions we had
people who were not monitored at all
people who were monitored
developmentally and people who were
monitored kind of evaluative ly
administrative ly alright so here's
here's the results the first set of
graphs they're the declarative knowledge
test no differences so as far as those
little check up tests they took
throughout it didn't matter whether they
were monitored or not they performed
about the same but if you look at the
final skills test you see that people
who were monitored developmentally
performed a full point better than
people who were not monitored so their
performance was noticeably better and if
you look at how long they spent
reviewing tasks
all right people who were monitored
developmentally spent twice as long or
viewing the task as people who were
monitored administrative ly so again I
know I started off by talking about how
monitoring can focus people's goals in a
very particular way well that also
depends on how its framed and how its
communicated to people we can achieve
very useful learning outcomes with a
very simple kind of framing manipulation
I also asked people what they thought
about this training experience and so I
asked them first how useful did this
training seem to you did you feel like
you got something out of it people who
were monitored developmental you felt
like it was marginally more useful I
asked them how fair did it seem that we
tracked her behavior people who were
monitored developmental he felt like it
was marginally more fair and then I
asked them did you feel like your
privacy was invaded first thing to
notice is that nobody felt like their
privacy was very invaded right so on a
scale of one to five they were about as
low as you could be but the people with
administrative monitoring felt like it
was more of an invasion of privacy okay
so just to wrap up and Kyleigh some
really important conclusions from this
set of studies and there's an old
expression in organizational psychology
which is what you measure is what you
treasure meaning by putting a number on
something you give it importance and
then it drives future behavior
the
is a serious problem if you measure the
wrong thing and we usually measure the
wrong thing because it's easier right so
you just count whatever is laying around
and then all of a sudden it takes on all
sorts of importance and what I would
argue for is using theory to support
appropriate data collection um it's also
very clear from these studies and others
that I haven't presented today that
measurement directs the goals of the
people that's being measured and so if
you direct the goals in the wrong
direction
you'll have some problems we know that
measurement can be a source of
distraction in a in a another study I
ran around online interviews I took the
little picture of yourself that shows up
in a Skype interview right and I either
had it there or took it away and just
that little stimulus of someone can see
you all right all of a sudden people are
messing with their hair a little bit
more all right they're a little bit
distracted and their performance on the
interview went down because of this
extra source of distraction it doesn't
take much
we're fragile human beings we only have
so much attention and measurement is a
source of distraction but not all people
are affected the same way and not all
measurement has the same effects and the
last thing I would say is that when I
hear security experts talking about
surveillance they say things like you
have to be smart about privacy right you
have to be smart and then you read
things like oh all the privacy policies
that you encounter in a year would take
you 76 days to read and nobody knows
what a privacy policy is and they've
never heard of it and they don't know
how to understand it right this suggests
that if we just had all the information
we would make these wonderfully perfect
decisions but that's not how humans work
all right we have motivations we have
goals we have preferences and in the
studies that I presented to you people
made an informed decision about sharing
or not sharing being surveilled or not
being surveilled and it doesn't mean
they're not smart right so I would like
to argue for a slightly more nuanced way
of thinking about privacy and
surveillance based on the fact that we
are humans with agency and can make
decisions do I think the study that puts
the finest point on that
argument is one of my favorites I can't
take any credit for it it was a study of
college students and so they interviewed
a bunch of college students and they
said should you if you receive a link
from an anonymous person should you
click on it and seventy-five percent of
people said oh no no do not click on
that link and then the same researchers
emailed the same college students and
said check out these pictures from last
night with a fake leg and you know what
everyone clicked on that link everyone
dead right and it's because we're making
a decision what if there's cool pictures
in there right what if what if there's
an embarrassing picture in there and I
need to verify it this is a logical
decision on the part of the college
students and so again it's not about
being smart um so thank you to my
collaborators here and I look forward to
your questions
[Applause]
thank you so much and there we are good
so we're gonna take questions from from
the audience I may need to hand you this
mic to do it so think of your questions
one thing we CH other a little bit about
this earlier so as you were talking
about that Facebook app and that
experience there was something in the
news I don't know if anybody read a
guardian article that had to do with the
Trump campaigns data side this weekend
but there's they're sort of a relation
here maybe you can talk about what how
some of that data relates to and is not
the the data that appears in the Trump
okay so to clarify I'm not funded by
Robert Mercer or Breitbart yes I hope
that was obvious because I don't have
horns anyway right so yeah but some of
you might have read about this story
about Cambridge analytic Oh which is a
marketing company and the premise of
this organization is to use the same
kind of Facebook data that I presented
to give people ads that are personalized
to their personality and therefore
manipulate and change their behavior and
perhaps you can tell from my tone I'm
highly skeptical about the effectiveness
of this approach but you it's along the
lines of if you're extroverted I'll show
you an ad with lots of people having fun
at a party if you're introverted I'll
show you an ad with one person reading a
book or if you're neurotic I'll show you
a picture of like a person with a gun
coming to shoot you so that you're
scared there's very little evidence that
people are so easily manipulated so I
would point that out that this is not
you know the AI coming to brainwash you
that everyone seems to think it is it's
I heard a great talk last week from
friend of mine Jeff Hancock who pointed
out that in the 30s everyone is afraid
of subliminal advertising right
brainwashing you but I'm pretty sure we
didn't turn in
well maybe we did yeah
so if this is a progression of something
that has been kind of in our minds for a
long time as far as the connection of
the data itself it is similar data but
not the same data and the data that I
presented to you is collected for
research purposes only and it's actually
public data and so anyone who would like
to can obtain it if they like and we
have so so Rio's gonna be taking your
questions so catch her eye if you want
to ask a question and while she's
finding somebody have one from the
livestream I didn't mention thanks
everybody's listening on a live stream
so this is someone who first of all like
the talk a lot and has worked in like
telemarketing so phone center things
where there's all kinds of data that's
being collected and in those kinds of
environments and they're asking the
question have you looked at at that Zoo
and and maybe this points to so I don't
know if you've got worked with that data
specifically but maybe you want to talk
a bit about how you look at how
organizations businesses as they're
interacting with their employees more
directly some of some of the work that
you've done in that area um sure so I
think that's two different questions
into answer both of them as far as
whether anyone has looked at call
centers which are pervasively monitored
absolutely in fact a lot of a lot of the
research in the early 2000s exploring
whether electronic surveillance was
similar to in-person surveillance that
data was all collected from call centers
because everything you do when you work
on a call center is tracked and heavily
regulated and we do see social
facilitation effects occur I've talked
to people from all sorts of
organizational backgrounds and the same
kinds of dynamics show up everywhere
about 25 percent of the people in a
recent study I conducted were monitored
pervasively so it's not just cause
hunters it's it's actually not limited
by job complexity either and in fact
people who are lawyers and doctors and
professors are also monitored
pervasively and you know if you've got a
ID tag with an RFID chip right and your
locations are
that counts and so absolutely your other
question as far as the organization's I
work with and and how this comes up you
know I started off by saying that not
all surveillance is bad and I really do
believe that and I work with a lot of
government agencies NGOs who are
interested in problems like workforce
readiness and skills development for
their most vulnerable citizens and you
can use big data and you can use
surveillance to help people develop
skills all right so I don't want to
throw the baby out with the bathwater
here because I've seen it used really
effectively with respect for individuals
and respect for autonomy I think that is
possible I think we've got a question
over here oh yeah strikes me that there
might be a difference between
surveillance where I know who is
surveilling me in the workplace for
example and surveillance where I kind of
know I'm being watched but I don't know
who's surveilling me maybe on the
internet how do people react or do they
react differently in those situations
yeah that's a great question and so in
another study I conducted recently I was
interested in the people who don't know
how they're surveilled and that's
actually the worst outcome so knowing
who's monitoring you and for what
purpose people can be okay with that
right they can and understand that and
adopt to it but wondering having a lack
of transparency is an incredible threat
to our sense of justice and it also
doesn't inform us about how to behave at
all and so we're left in this state of
wandering and an uncertainty that's very
bad for well-being yeah and I'm sure we
all feel that right now yep thank you
for a very interesting talk I was really
intrigued by the study of connections
between the personality traits and one's
opinions about surveillance I was
wondering you have you and your team
your lab or anyone else in your field
done a study where connections between
ones sort of moral foundations and
opinions about morality or oh sorry
opens up a surveillance or answers to
these situations about surveillance have
been measured what I'm thinking more the
works of like people like Richard
shredder and and Jonathan Haidt on
foundations and moral foundations of
psychology I do think your values have a
lot to do with how you react to
surveillance the relationship between
values and personality is kind of up for
debate and I chose to focus on
personality but I could have easily also
looked at values again if you're an
authoritarian and your value system
right then the way you think about
morality is driven by that and so you'll
be more okay with surveillance although
this is an emerging area and I couldn't
exploit you any really great Studies on
the topic I've got one I'm curious as to
how you feel about the idea of
sousveillance I mean if if one of the
directions that we're going is more and
more surveillance to a point where
everyone's watching everybody and the
amount of directions are kind of
untrackable at some point of all
surveillance all the time are there
where where does that kind of limit
start ending and in social interaction
and if it's so prevalent does it all
stop mattering again it's a great
question and it's sort of see violence
which is the idea of you know
surveillance means someone with power
over seeing someone without power
sousveillance is the other direction
right someone without power serving or
keeping an eye on the Watchers and so we
are seeing more technologies built to do
just that the other part of your
question is far as how that means we
might change the way we think about
what's private in public I think that's
a really important thing to think more
about how our identities change when
there is nothing left to really hide I
personally think and I don't have any
data for this I personally think being
able to keep some things private is
really important and valuable and it
shapes your identity but in terms of
data I can't offer you any and before we
take the next question so you're working
what as you're part of your cosmos
fellowship you're working on a book
right now about this to one you know say
a thing or two about is this at the
center of it is this all that's in there
what's what's the scope of the project
you're working on right now I'm sure so
yes this eventually will turn into a
book within the next 20 30 years or so
you taking down payments now right yes I
do you accept advances so it will be
about this research that I've connected
about how people react to surveillance
but also how we can use it to accomplish
really important societal goods the
other thing I'm working on at casbahs
that I do want to mention is that I am
part of a partnership with the Casbah
and the Stanford cyber initiative which
is an organization meant to help
understand the intersections between
social systems and cyber systems I mean
I'm a psychologist and that's very clear
from my perspective I think a lot of
these questions are not about the
technology but about the people about
the psychology so the point of this year
is to help foster those connections even
more and and there are lots of
interesting activities happening with
the cyber initiative around those themes
I was gonna mention I think there might
be a third and modality that you were
that we haven't addressed when it comes
to whether it's your employer surveying
what you're doing as part of your job
and someone surveying in terms of
offering you offers that are things are
useful to you the third one is work just
collecting all the data because we don't
know what we want to use it for but
we're just gonna point a bunch of you
know big data at it and figure out in
the future what those things mean and
there seems to be a very big risk of
making conclusions about people that
aren't necessarily true and that it's
based on you know obviously whoever's
sending something will look at the data
and say this proves this thing and
there's a hell of a lot of that stuff
going on right now especially with like
the NSA snooping and just basically
gathering everything right right you're
absolutely right and this is again an
extension of the good hearts law idea
that just because we observe a pattern
doesn't mean that that pattern will be
useful in the future and we have very
little understanding of what those
patterns really mean there's a lot of
great examples of this and I won't run
through all of them but
in the context of organizations we have
algorithms that make hiring decisions
right who to hire who not to hire based
on whoever's currently in the
organization and it turns out a lot of
those algorithms are racist right like
they're just terrible and the danger is
having the data assuming that you know
what it means and then extrapolating to
the future especially when the data as
we just saw it changes people's behavior
alright so we know that it's biased in a
very particular direction I think you're
right a lot of people are just grabbing
as much data as they can with the hope
of either monetizing it later or finding
a pattern later and I think that's
really dangerous
you've Dutch t' on examples of where the
surveillance has a benefit and where i
think it was just touched on very
briefly was where there were was
community training I thought you said
where groups were brought together and
they needed to learn something together
I it's a bad example I can see from your
face but where would you just touch on
where elaborate on examples of where
surveillance has had positive sir I
think maybe what you're referring to is
the early social facilitation research
about having a group of people around
you enhancing your performance
surveillance is generating value and
we're better off because clarity
transparency
and and and maybe one of the things say
is that surveillance itself as the term
becomes very charged so maybe it's we're
calling it something else it is yeah so
so other cases where and and there's
some of those in the workplace that
would be examples maybe you can talk
about so great so data collection for
the purpose of providing some service I
think that's ubiquitous and in the
context of learning let's say I am a
teacher and I have 300 students and I
have no way of intervening with a
student before they're on the wrong
course right but if I've got a lot of
behavioral data about them early and
then a little dashboard pops up and says
hey Janet
is on the wrong course you should
intervene I can save that student from
flunking out that's really powerful the
question is is Janet okay with this
right are they have they been informed
about the fact that everything about
their behavior is collected and so it's
not about the tool it's not about the
data it's about the process right how is
the data collected but also how is it
communicated to the person who's
supposedly receiving a benefit from it
because I think a lot of the services we
talk about that rely on data collection
do offer a benefit some people think
Facebook is an essential good all right
so that we need Facebook and it relies
on data collection that decision I think
is made on an individual basis whether
the service is valuable enough to give
up the data one of the things we haven't
really touched on are there any models
where the surveillance happens and the
person who is surveilled who is recorded
gets to see that data or that recording
because it seems like that would be a
model where people could see and and and
react themselves to it not just that
somebody in the booth gets to like see
everything you've been doing or are
there examples of this there are and a
great one is if anyone ever works from
home sometimes you're expected to be
available on video camera just to make
sure you're not doing your laundry for
example right I totally do my laundry
when I work anyway and there will be a
little light that shows up to say your
boss is using your webcam and looking to
see what you're up to or even just that
you're available on chat right there
a little green button that says you're
available so there are these feedback
mechanisms all over the place to say
someone's potentially looking at you
right now and generally people like that
because again it's worse to not know in
fact across the number of studies I've
conducted it's very clear that the worst
possible phenomenon is shouldn't have no
idea what's going on and so if you are
informed about what's being collected
and you have an understanding about why
it's being collected people are
generally okay with that you can take it
one level up and give people control
over whether the cameras on right so in
most cases I can hit a little button
when I need to be away from my desk you
know turn the camera off and then I can
turn it back on when I return the fact
that I have control over it is great and
most people never even use the button
which is knowing that the buttons there
is really nice one other example is
probably a lot of people have heard
about is got publicity is body cams on
cops do you have anything to say about
that because there I've heard research
there that shown positive things
happening but I don't know what's what's
do you have a take on that is that been
something you've looked at at all yeah
so my perspective would be how it
influences the police officers right and
good and bad because as you know they're
highly manipulatable right so I can
change the my body angle so that
whatever I'm doing that's bad is not on
the camera I can turn it off at the
crucial moment the cameras do change
behavior but as I mentioned earlier it
doesn't mean that it changes it in a
super positive way all the time right it
just means that people will optimize
whatever is on the camera but they'll
find all kinds of sneaky ways around it
if they are the sneaky sort and there's
some really interesting kind of ongoing
research in that area and the city of
DC's got this great initiative it's
called the lab the lab at DC I believe
and so they're running our huge study
right now about police body cams and I
think that data will be out soon enough
we got one in the back there you showed
a graph from the face book study showing
that people got less willing to share
their information as the years went on
there was a big drop up in the first
year
then it kind of continued a little bit
have you seen other studies that
suggested that trend continued and we're
getting more sensitive to this sort of
stuff it's a great question I've not
seen any other studies that show a
similar pattern but I think we can all
hypotheses about why we saw the pattern
that we did which is that from 2009 to
2012 there was a lot of information
coming out about the fact that we needed
to start being more careful about what
we put online
2009 was still the Wild West right who
knows what was going on in 2009 but the
other factor in that data is that far
fewer people completed the survey in
2012 than they did in 2010 so it's not
necessarily 100% representative that
trend got a lot of interest here so you
know one there yeah hi thank you for a
great talk from long now perspective
taking it further back about 150 years
there was you lived in small societies
and and everyone you have what was
happening with you and even further back
you didn't really have any walls inside
of your home so everyone knew exactly
what you were doing at all times have
you made any like thoughts and
comparisons from that perspective yeah I
think the idea of privacy actually only
belongs to a very small moment in time
right it didn't exist before and it
probably won't exist in the future but
it exists right now and so we're
thinking about it right now but that's a
great point that you know small
communities of people where everybody
knows everything about each other
it's a form of social control all right
you can't act out because everyone will
know about it and your 10 auntie's will
come yell at you alright so so that's
absolutely the keys and you can think of
online data is just another extension of
that alright and I think that's gonna be
our last question for the night Patel
you're gonna stick around so I know
there are a few more questions please
definitely come up and get Tara to
answer them I want to let's have a big
round of applause for Tara
have you a long now challenge going to
thank you so much for for speaking for
us again she's gonna be here thanks to
all of you for coming out please do
stick around talk to each other talk to
Tara and do come back and see us we've
got a lot more great talks coming out
[Music]